[Music]
hello and welcome my name is Jake I'm
here with Justin and we just played some
Monster Hunter Justin here you've been a
fan for quite a while you're excited for
this game yeah that this Monster Hunter
it is definitely the best-looking one in
a while I don't know if that's a fair
comparison because the versions you had
previously have quite a while then on
mobile platforms and I feel like that's
kind of what we've associated Monster
Hunter with but this one bringing it to
the the ps4 and the Xbox one the PC like
you can tell how how much care has gone
into creating this world now I think
there are a lot of games of course that
are better looking like you're not gonna
look at this compared to horizon zero
dawn or something like that but it's
still a really good looking game and I
think that's and that's something that's
to know for you as well as someone who's
kind of dabbled in the series what did
you think of it visually yeah I thought
it was a huge improvement of course
before it was on 3ds right and I think
some Vita or know some PSP games correct
and back in the day it was on ps2 back
in the ps2 days of course it was
something that really stood out like
there was something that pushed the
playstation platform but going to the
the mobile platforms after that you're
always gonna have a sacrifice to in
graphics to some degree do you think
this is a good transition based on what
you played from mobile to console so I
think that's the really interesting
thing about the game is that it feels
incredibly faithful to the original
games that the doors for definitely for
better for worse it Monster Hunter is
known for being brutally difficult to
get into it is not a game that's as a
game itself it's not very friendly to
newcomers it really helps to have
somebody who knows what they're doing
someone who's had experience with it and
going into it it feels like a monster
hunter game which is great like for
somebody who's played monster hunter
you're able to jump back into the same
weapons and the same roles and start
taking down these monsters in a very
very familiar sense for somebody who
might be new to it it's it'll be
really interesting to see how they
handle tutorials I think that was
something Monster Hunter generations did
a good job with but Monster Hunter as a
whole has always been known as one of
those series where the best way to learn
the game is by watching people play it
on YouTube and having some in-depth
explanations for how these combos work
how how to put all of the learnings that
you get from the game together because
it's very text heavy that's something
that we didn't really get a feel for is
how they're going to onboard new players
for returning players you're gonna be
able to jump right into this game with
the familiar iconography with the
familiar weapons it's just a really
familiar gameplay for someone who again
who hasn't played as much how did it
feel playing the game
youyou've dallied around with it a bit
did you do you think it was difficult
did you think it was something that you
could just jump right into I think it
was easier for me to jump into as
opposed to the handheld version I'm kind
of a sucker for visuals and it's easier
for me to get involved in a world like
that and I did play some of Monster
Hunter 4 I played about 20 hours but I
have some friends who are really into it
and they all told me that is barely
scratching the surface yeah you didn't
even start they get 20 hours that's
tutorial that's basically what I've
heard so playing this and seeing the
game with that kind of visual fidelity
has me a lot more interested I can
definitely tell that 30 minutes or
however much we played is definitely not
enough for me to really understand what
was going on
however the like I said before I think
that visual flair adds a lot and I am
definitely more interested in this then
I would be if they were coming out with
one on 3ds and the reason that it has
been on mobile platforms for such a long
time now is because that's the best way
to get a group of people together and I
feel like especially now with the
architecture behind consoles like ps4
and Xbox one that it is easier to get
those groups together and there's
something that they're introducing that
the games that they haven't done before
which is the ability to jump into a game
at any point previously you would have
to form a party why the menus you have
to dig through in there I'm gonna guess
there's still quite a few menus but if
you see if you need help you're able to
send up a flare and if someone else is
playing the game or they're on their ps4
they're gonna be able to jump into your
game and I think that is by itself just
a huge game changer for
making that more accessible so I think
the biggest question though is so
Monster Hunter has always been pretty
successful in Japan this do you think
monsters are coming to ps4 monster
underworld could be the breakthrough it
needs in the US market
I think the graphics are something that
have obviously a hang-up for a lot of
people and and visually this is a game
that I think is gonna peak a lot more
people's interest not being on 3ds not
being something that kind of looks like
I wouldn't say kiddie because it's
always been a really good-looking game
but not something that's compromising
its visuals for its gameplay because you
have such a strong gameplay hook with
Monster Hunter it's something like I I
mean you look at Dark Souls Dark Souls
is brutally difficult it's a game that
not everybody can get into and it takes
a long time to really wrap your head
around how to live in that world and
monster hunters that same way but
monster hunters all are Dark Souls is
beautiful blood-borne are beautiful in a
sense they they create really compelling
visual atmospheres really well done in
Monster Hunter I think has the chance to
do that alright right now we've only
seen kind of jungle environment but if
there's a lot of a right in places you
can go to that's something that's really
gonna help this game and then the other
thing is how well are they gonna onboard
new players because there are gonna be a
lot of people who never have played
Monster Hunter not even people who just
played it back in the day like I think
this will be the first monster hunter
for a lot of people and if it's to
punishing if it's to hard to get into
games or if it's just too hard to find
people to play with that'll be the the
thing that doesn't allow Monster Hunter
to succeed as we've seen previously
there is such a strong community around
these games I think that's the thing
that's gonna help push monster 100 world
to finally get at least a modicum of
success probably more success than any
previous Monster Hunter game I I am
really optimistic about this game
pushing the that Monster Hunter
franchise which has been so crazy
popular in Japan and making it at least
something that is on a lot more people's
radar in the US
and when does this come out so right now
there's not a firm release state they're
saying early 2018 so you know I'm
guessing probably late spring uh
definitely before III I don't think
they're gonna wait that much longer to
do it but you also have to think there's
a lot of stuff going on in to be put
into this game if it gets delayed that's
not terribly unsurprising but right now
it sounds like they're aiming for late
spring cool I'm looking forward to
playing that when it finally comes out
in 2018 and for more Gamescom coverage
make sure to stay-tuned the game
spotting have plenty of stuff coming at
you so hit that subscribe button thank
you
[Music]